la pandemia de coronavirus ha empeorado
en algunas regiones rusas a pesar de un
cierre de empresas y de la mayoría de
los establecimientos comerciales durante
una semana en diversos puntos del país
una medida pensada para intentar frenar
las infecciones muchos cafés
restaurantes y también algunos comercios
estaban ya al borde del cierre por este
parón impuesto por el gobierno pero a
cambio los progresos han sido modestos
la inmunidad colectiva en el país se
sitúa en torno al 48 por ciento una
ligera mejora respecto al 46 por ciento
de una semana antes cuando iba a empezar
el cierre de casi todos los
establecimientos comerciales salvo
tiendas de alimentación y farmacias ante
este complicado panorama cinco regiones
han decidido extender los días no
laborables anunciados por el presidente
vladimir putin el mes pasado otras
regiones como ésta moscú han vuelto al
trabajo hoy lunes eso si en algunos
sitios se requerirá a los clientes oa
los visitantes que presenten un código
qr para demostrar su inmunidad